I hate buzz words but I think matching
people planet and profits is not a bad
one if you have to have one and I think
that you know I think first of all
people who create businesses you have to
ask you know what what what are they
doing what they're doing is trying to
make a difference to people's lives and
if you make a difference a positive
difference to people's lives you're
gonna have a successful business you
know but business should not be just
about the shareholders and should not be
just about the bottom line you know if
you're running a business you should be
making a difference to people and making
a different difference to the world and
and that difference to the world should
be in there's many different areas as
you can you can possibly you know you
can possibly cope with you know and
there's no question that you know try
trying to work towards a cleaner world
should should be on the list I think of
every you know chief executive chairman
presidents of businesses agenda
you